we were doing out like trash we had
electric shock treatments to make us
straight we had so many horrible things
happen to us I think one of the hard
things about being a transgendered or
gay person or anything different than
what the normal elk is is that they
don't feel as if you belong and they
make sure that you understand that at
every given moment in the beginning
there was a lot of bullying so just
being who you are and how you presented
yourself and this was in New Jersey in
the 1950s there was always the threat of
physical attack and assault so it kept
you on your toes it also made you very
anxious I went to an all-girls school
and I was constantly being pulled out of
class to be counseled by the nuns the
Catholic nuns who were telling me all
kinds of things that they were actually
you know not in support of like go and
get yourself a boyfriend go and put on
some makeup grow your hair long I do not
want to be this way
I really didn't I wanted to be like
normal little boys so I decided one day
that I would join the military if the
military can't make me a man nothing
will I think gay bars you know
particularly at the time I was coming
around really provided a sanctuary
you can relax be with people that you
liked that hopefully liked you back and
kind of forget the outside world and all
the discrimination and hate one of the
thing that the police were doing when
they were arresting us at that time was
putting us at hospitals because they
thought that we were mentally insecure
and that we were deranged people by
wanting to just in the man that we chose
instead of putting us in jail it's
changed since then and now we go
directly to jail and we're filling that
up
you speak there is this laissez-faire
okay well you know
alright gay people here but like they
can't be married oh yeah but I don't
wanted to be my doctor no no no no I
would love people like that to learn
from Orlando that they've had
responsibility for what happens then in
Atlanta they're not absolved we come a
long way but we still have a long way to
go because transgender girls and boys
are still being killed because of who
they were mentioning it hasn't stopped
it's just the hatred of the community of
us being different